[Music]
facebook is taking new steps to protect
the election with less than a month to
go
the company says it will stop running
issue and political ads
after polls close november third the
game the aim is to reduce what it calls
opportunities for confusion or abuse
this comes a day after the company
banned groups supporting the bogus
conspiracy theory known as q anon
which portrays president trump as a
secret warrior jamie yucas now shows us
why facebook
is tightening the reins we're going to
take this
seriously as he told gail king last
month facebook ceo mark zuckerberg has
been under increasing pressure
to monitor and control political content
he says he wants to be sure that
campaigns don't use the platform to
declare
victory prematurely or argue an ongoing
vote count means the election is rigged
i think that that would be dangerous i
think it would be kind of delegitimizing
of the election
and i think it could risk increasing you
know people getting into the streets and
civil unrest
after the election which i think would
be very problematic at the time of that
september interview
facebook banned new political ads the
week prior to the election
but now it's extending that ban to all
political ads
after polls close as well with no set
end date
they're scared wired editor-in-chief
nicholas thompson believes
facebook executives are facing pressure
from employees
and the media to take action to better
control the platform's political content
they are worried that our democracy will
be destroyed in one way or another
and they don't want to have a role in
that join
army for trump's election security
operation
another new policy going forward ads
like this one
using so-called militarized language or
other ads that seem designed to
intimidate voters or
election officials will be removed but
such ads already
on the platform will not be taken down
they've
almost built a monster they can't tame
and they're trying their hardest right
now this action is coming relatively
late for facebook with less than a month
before the election
last month alphabet inc which owns
google said it would block election
related ads
after the polls close also for in an
indefinite period
and twitter has already banned all
political ads anthony
all right jamie thank you